you still had to make 81. is this still
a tough cut here
no this one was relatively easy this is
going all the way back to 2008 so this
is the summer before the games this
probably happened in
june i would say
so this is the
olympic trial so in the united states
you have to i mean similar to like
wrestling you have to win the trials to
qualify for that particular division to
represent the united states so this is
you said june before an august olympics
yep
so here i just wanted to show this match
because uh
what was there there's another one i
think you do a pin you do some there's
groundwork in the other one but in this
one
fighting a teammate
fighting a teammate former teammate oh
there's an old school double leg i
forgot about that and it's weird to
see so you so there
um the travis's opponent and he's travis
is setting up here that sanagi
uh posting his
left arm and getting it done that's a
big that's a big throw
you have too many of those big throws on
uh
on video
because like you often on video you're
going against the best people in the
world it's tough to get like that much
air
and a lot of times the the ones that we
do see and you know the part that a lot
of people don't
experience is
a lot of those times where i threw
people with that throw
it was in training camps
so by the time i got to the competition
with these guys
they were playing a hundred percent
defense to never let me do that yeah
so you do this
um here are you kind of pulling him down
no he's i'm trying to get him to come up
to come up but are you pulling him down
to get to fake him off i'm not doing
anything with my left hand
uh so here the the opponent's so what
i'm doing right now is his head is like
in my chest i'm pressing him to get his
head to lift with my chest
so i'm pressing his hand down so i can
use my chest to like pinch my scaps and
roll his head up so he wants to pick it
up
and
and then he i mean doesn't he know
what's coming here oh no he might not
oh no he knew he was a former teammate
he knew exactly what i was trying to do
and that was a really big step with your
foot it covers uh about four feet
so you use the distance
and your left
um
catches up in like perfect position yeah
you back it up a little bit
keep going
right there that's this is like an
important distinction between mine and
everybody else's is
because i split his hip
um i actually once i'm able to split i
no longer need
his center of gravity below mine
right and when you say split you mean
you put your foot in between
my do that split that four foot split
yes and then when i get my feet back
together it doesn't matter that i'm
under his center gravity or not yeah
that's why my chest is right around his
like
sternum height
for me
yeah so so the there i mean how does he
get uh for people just listening to this
travis steps is like that's like a big
huge step gets
like my hip is probably right around his
nipple
because he's he's sprawled back so much
yeah that's right
so like so you're how does the physics
of this work you're violating the
principle of
your center of mass being under oh i
guess somehow it is
i don't know but he has nowhere to go
he's screwed yes that's the kicker is
the way my
mind works is
in order for him to play an effective
defense
he needs to have his feet firmly planted
on the ground with friction
yeah otherwise he can't press into me to
stop it so when i get him to sprawl back
when i split his legs he effectively
loses that contact with the floor even
though his feet are on the floor
they're not in a position where he can
drive from them yeah therefore when i
flip he flips
so there's a
so there's a natural like flailing here
so he's not falling forward
you're falling forward yeah he's just
attached to you so like
you can keep them up there and their
like legs would be just flailing yep one
of my one of my golden rules when i'm
training and i get really tired
one of the like mantras i would always
tell myself is i'm going to put my back
on your chest and then i'm going to put
my back on the floor
yeah because then you'll be underneath
me that's a good principle
very simple and it regardless of like
all the chaos and how quickly things are
happening
it's something i can just dumb
everything down to and focus on
regardless of the gripping situation the
footwork all of that get my back to your
chest and then put my back on the floor
so this step of getting your back to
their chest
um like for for people who are sort of
more like for example for people like me
who are just like amateur judo people
like there's all kinds of ways to
prevent this turn
from happening the gripping and just
everything
how difficult is it at the highest level
to get
into this position i mean you make it
look effortless often but like to get to
a position where you're from facing them
to
your backs to them is that like strategy
is that timing is that timing
it's timing
it's like anything like if i wanted to
punch you in the face like how hard is
it to really do that if you know you can
just play defense and block it yeah the
trick is to get them to play defense to
something that never happened
and then you go through like another way
and then you just go through what would
technically be your first plan if you
planned on them playing defense
so i set the stage from the very
beginning for this to work
so then this your uh you're celebrating
here it's a huge
sort of
once a big accomplishment big relief to
qualify for the olympics
and then you go into the olympics and
this is where i first saw judo
and
i kind of thought of them as the same as
judo and jiu-jitsu um
and i was really impressed by your
performance in that olympics
the footage nowhere to be found these
days but uh
um at that time i think you could still
you could watch it live on nbc olympics
or somewhere like that and i remember
watching several of your matches
one of them was the match against ollie
bischoff the german
and i remember being it'd be nice if you
can talk to that match because i don't
remember it all i remember
is being frustrated
yep
by
him
not letting you play judo yeah
so
obviously you faced him again four years
later and there's a lot of frustration
there as well but i remember being extra
frustrated in 2008.
what was that match like so he he might
have been number one in the world at the
time or up there he was up there for
sure um especially going into 2008.
he was really high up there yeah and did
he win
gold at that olympics
yes yeah because he silvered in london
it was the same olympic
final both in 2008 and london yeah okay
so you're facing
him there
were you intimidated what was the
strategy can you talk to that match
because it kind of sets the stage for
the rematch in 2012. yeah he was
somebody that i had trained with in the
past and for some reason when it comes
to him and i
when we train together
it's more of a physical altercation than
a judo training session
you know like it's just like the coaches
have had to break us up a few times like
oh you guys get almost like angry too
a little bit it always goes you know
farther than it should for
we're friends like we say hello to each
other but for some reason when we train
together there's something about like
him and me that just
oil and water i don't know what it is it
could be also the gripping because he's
a great gripping strategist yeah it does
he frustrates you with certain kinds of
grips and then you get pissed off and
you frustrate him and then he gets
pissed off and then before you know it
somebody's kicked somebody or punched
somebody in the mouth or done something
yeah so one of the only evidences we
have online of you fighting him is you
your foot in his
groin area is the only thing we have
from that olympics from 2008 from 2008
yeah and to answer everybody's question
yes it was deliberate
now you can say this yeah but yeah i
remember there being a lot of
frustration
uh you go you're actually going for a
lot of stuff like sacrifice those i mean
maybe you're not going for the highest
scoring e-pawns but you're just trying
to shake things up if i remember
correctly yeah because when he i was so
young then that and he was you know in
his prime really at that time right he
was must have been
24 25 26 you know
world medalist european champion at the
time
and when he would grab me i would i had
that sense of feeling stuck
like i was strong enough if i used all
my strength to
not let him do anything but then you
can't be offensive when you're using all
your strength to
hold on to the situation
so i was getting really aggravated
because i couldn't i couldn't generate
any offense with every time i felt like
i gained an advantage in the gripping
scenario
he would take some obscure grip
somewhere that was like
well now i've got to go address this
thing give up what i gained and i have
to go back and
it if i were to think about watching the
match now it'd probably look like a lot
of flailing because we're just trying to
generate
enough to not get a penalty but also not
enough to where he could counter it
did you think you were you could beat
him like when you were walking into the
match
until i gripped him for the first time
like
i cuz i had trained with him before he
felt stronger and more in shape than
i've ever felt him
that day the olympics at that olympics
which begs a whole nother question
but
[Laughter]
i remember when i when he grabbed me for
that first time i went this is different
and i there was a sense of panic at the
time because i was like
holy crap where did this come from this
is not the guy
that i've trained with that i expected
because it was a definite like
level change in like his ability
strength speed and stamina
like looking back at that can you
explain that is it just you being more
uh less confident because of the
olympics it was
is there some kind of routine that he
followed to like really level up an
intensity for this particular event i've
been told that
he only gets to like his prime
for like really big events yeah like he
doesn't train like year-round like i
would train but when it comes to like
the games he doesn't do social media he
doesn't work he lives breathes eats
his training for the games which could
you know institute that level
what about you is there uh like dan
gable famously said like the one loss he
had in college he was doing a lot of
media and stuff back back then there was
no social media that was a huge mistake
for him
do you do social media do you do like at
that at this point what that time was
like aol i don't know
i didn't even have a facebook page uh
myspace nothing at this point yeah i got
my first facebook page from the usoc in
2012. yeah when i went through the media
thing the lady was like
you have to have it i go i don't want it
i don't like people i want to deal with
the people
what am i supposed to do you know like
the social part of the social media
okay um i i have to bring this up
because uh and then you went on to face
diago camilo uh you lost that match but
he went on to win bronze that's also an
interesting one but we can skip ahead i
just remember being really impressed
both by your ground work
um that was a match i should have won
yeah i should have won that i was
if you don't know judo
you would visually watch that and be
like i'm winning but he was technically
winning on the scoreboard so it is what
it is but the point that he got that
solidified his win
yes it was a point back in those days so
i can't say anything but like
my shoulder nicked the ground so it's
like i don't know yeah a lot of the
stories of your olympic career is like
from a fan perspective it seems like
you should have won or you very close to
could have won yes and there was a lot
of frustration you and your game being
like shut down in certain ways and
but like
the thing that immediately grabbed me in
was how much something about the way you
approached judo
how much you wanted to win
because i was young then
i was
when i was at this at this time in my
career
i was out to like
win like there was no like i'm gonna
grab you i'm gonna throw you and if not
you're gonna go through a battle yeah
you're gonna make sure you earned it
you